and i'm just going to say something else
they may edit this out
there was a lot of wetness in this movie
a lot of wetness but you could see the
freaking water soaked into his like
and then i think he was a moist boy in
this movie he was a moist boy i'll leave
it there
hello hello hello everybody i'm nikki
novak and welcome to another episode of
the after show
this is a big one folks we are talking
about
the batman and the riddler
but we're talking about the film the
batman we're going to be deep diving
into all the beats of the film and then
eventually we're going to talk about the
burning questions that the film left
behind if this continues it won't be
long before you've nothing left
i don't care what happens to me
it's only going to get worse for you
i'm so excited to talk about this little
indie movie and we have a very special
guest today
adam flavic how are you i am doing
excellent i'm super excited to be here
um looking forward to talking about this
movie and uh getting everybody's
thoughts because i did love it spoilers
i'm super psyched to talk to you about
it because i actually just it's so fresh
for me i just saw it last night
and so i have and i haven't talked to
anybody about it yet so i'm
and i know you're you're a super fan of
this genre so yeah um so first let's
just
go over a little bit about the films
it's directed by matt reeves it stars
robert pattinson zoe kravitz paul dano
colin farrell jeffrey wright andy circus
john tutturo
peter sarsgaard a little more a little
more down the line but we'll leave it at
that this is the 11th live-action batman
film it's set in a different universe
from batfleck from our boy ben affleck
um the most recent iteration of a live
action batman
the tomato meter score is currently 86
it is certified fresh the audience score
is 89 percent it made a huge 128 million
dollars domestically at the box office
over the weekend 249
million dollars worldwide and here's the
critic consensus on the film a grim
gritty and gripping super noir the
batman ranks among the dark knight's
bleakest and most thrillingly ambitious
live-action
outings
what say you adam do you concur
consensus on this phone you sort of gave
us a little teaser but expound yeah i
mean i would say of all the batman
movies it definitely definitely is one
of the
darker entries in this entire franchise
but i think when you get a director like
matt reeves on the project that's kind
of to be expected i think that's a
pretty natural thing that's going to
occur
so while i do agree
it very much seeps into my into my veins
and i just absolutely fell in love with
this movie so yeah
okay
no one knows yet because i haven't
talked to anybody
but i am
beyond beyond beyond beyond in love with
this phone this is easily my favorite
batman movie easily it ticked all the
boxes that i wanted it to tick and i was
the person i was a little bit skeptical
like i i don't know how you felt but
when i heard the casting of robert
pattinson as much as i like him
he's a very different batman a different
actor than the actors we've we've seen a
lot of actors that are sort of
i want to say they're more like
like larger than life kind of thing
robert pattinson is much more sort of
like introspective and brooding in his
performances in my opinion i wasn't sure
how it was going to go okay so that said
a lot of people are using the word
masterpiece i get irritated when people
use the word masterpiece for film when
they just throw it out there like
opening weekend do you as well because
100 movies have to sit a bit they have
to age they have like a wine you have to
sit with them so adam how do you feel
about the word masterpiece does it apply
to this film in any way shape or form
that's a really great question you know
i also have mixed feelings about how
people throw around that word so easily
i think you know within 24 hours of a
film's release to already throw that
word around so i don't know currently
i'm not really going to throw around
that i think it's a masterpiece i do
think it's an incredibly well executed
film but i think i do need to sit with
it a little bit longer and maybe look at
the movies that influenced it and how
well it may be utilized some of those
themes and how it utilizes you know some
of the tech wizardry and because for me
masterpiece i think of like well what is
it doing that's fresh in terms of story
but also i do look at the tech behind it
of like well how is it helping us
advance filmmaking forward and i do
think that this movie is helping some
developing technologies definitely move
forward into the film into the more
general filmmaking um vocabulary but i i
do think i need some some time but i
would recommend that if people
are open to it to definitely look at the
movies that maybe inspired this or
inspired some of their favorite films to
have a really well-rounded understanding
of
why that term was even created and why
we apply it to certain movies
yeah i think i'm the sa it's funny
because i had heard the term used for
this film and i saw very i saw it very
late compared to everybody else
and as i was watching it and i'm not a
person that enjoys that term because
i've even heard not just movie fans but
movie critics use that term quite often
like every film that comes out as a
masterpiece and it dilutes
the industry and it dilutes actually the
credibility for themselves and for the
film because if everything's a
masterpiece well then where what's the
next in between what's the next but
what's also better than masterpiece
right
so i just i but at but that said
as i was watching it i was like
something here like there's the reason
that i've got to concur with the whole
situation yeah and there was moments
that i was like and and the mastery of
the shop making the angles the povs the
lighting all of that but how many iconic
shots there were in that film like
there's a few movies that you think
about and i'm not going to name names
because i don't diss them but there's a
few because you think about and you
think about two or three iconic shots i
think this had so many um okay so maybe
not masterpiece level for you but is
this better than the dark knight
that's a spicy question
you know that's that's interesting
though because i have been
i have been comparing contrasting the
two and you know a lot of the times also
i kind of bring my personal experience
of watching these movies into it how did
they move me emotionally how did they
move me you know how excited was i
watching the film and for me truthfully
it is neck and neck like they both
and for for different reasons like the
dark knight one of the first major
motion pictures shot on imax film it was
an absolutely immersive mind-blowing
experience when i first saw it i didn't
know what to expect from that but then i
also got heath ledger i also got the
story i got this amazing score beautiful
cinematography so it really had all the
workings of what really made me excited
about it but then i went to go see this
and yes it doesn't have any imax
photography but it has kind of
everything else that
in my opinion the dark knight had it had
great performances great design you know
the production design the vehicles the
sound is absolutely amazing in this film
the cinematography greg frazier did an
amazing job with this thing so right now
i'm kind of like having an inner battle
with myself to figure out whether i
think one is better than the other or
whether i love them both equally and i
at the end of the day i i don't know if
i
necessarily need to have one be better
than the other like as a batman fan as a
fan of this genre i love the fact that i
have two movies that i consider to be so
good that i can't decide which one i
think is better than the other and i
think of course that's gonna vary from
person to person because your
experiences your cinematic experience is
different you know like we have people
who
have seen the batman in theaters who
maybe never got a chance to see the dark
knight in theaters which is crazy but
that is a possibility so i think you
know a lot of that also goes into
whether you decide which one you think
is better than the other
and i'm the same like as much as i
sometimes don't like the word
masterpiece i don't like comparisons but
we're gonna do it we're doing it today
but comparing movies because this one
and comparing actors who played the same
role but we're doing it anyway um
as best as we can with respect but i i
too feel like this rendition of batman i
mean i'm also a tim burton fan i loved
his batman movies like oh my god so much
guys are you yeah youtube man returns is
like the unsung hero of those four
original movies
and and also
it's like you said it's your experience
those were the first batman movies i
ever saw and so you're first how do you
compare anything into your first and
then you know just like even like the
batfleck universe the dceu is so
different from this how do you compare
and the dark knight i think the reason
why people are comparing them is because
they're considering them maybe the two
best live-action batmans and so you're
going to get that comparison um
that said i said it in the opening it is
because of what i like in a film
i loved how stylized it was
i loved that the choices were so
specific i loved bale as batman i always
thought he couldn't be topped yeah in my
opinion
but pattinson he came on and for me
and i want to ask you the question for
me
when he was batman i didn't see
pattinson like everybody talks about
colin farrell how he was unrecognizable
as the penguin yeah his voice
even his voice overs throughout i was
like sorry robert pattinson
he really didn't sound like himself i
know he's also doing an accent but
he didn't look like him sound like him
and it was so different and then when
you saw him as bruce wayne
i love the smokey eye i'm not gonna lie
i love a man with a smokey eye i had i
know it was
but it was also steeped in reference to
i'm not a comic book person but it's i
think from the comics or the graphic
novels i'm not really sure yeah there's
been a couple of graphic novels where
he's kind of embraced that embraced that
look but in all honesty i really think
it's just matt reeves going why are we
constantly removing the eye makeup and
pretending like it doesn't exist just
lean into it let it heal
and make them look all very emo you know
like yeah why not we don't have to have
these awkward shots and
returns where one shot there's eye
makeup and the next shot there's not i'm
like just let it live in the world but
he had no nipples i was i appreciated
that no nipples but so how did you feel
about robert pattinson as you know in
this role as a whole but
both both sort of characters that he was
playing well first of all i was actually
very excited for robert pattinson to
play this role mostly because you know i
know for years he kind of lived in the
twilight world and that's all people
knew him for
but he had done so many things after he
did the twilight movie you know
cosmopolis
uh good time which is like one of my
favorite movies of the last few years so
i was excited to see what else he could
do and i had a feeling that if he was
going to continue on this trajectory of
making a lot of these great indie films
that he could bring something very
unique to batman and kind of prove the
naysayers wrong and in my opinion he did
when it came to the portrayal batman you
know i grew up on the burton movies well
all the 90s films but i also grew up on
batman the animated series
and kevin conroy is
probably my nut will always probably be
my number one batman but i think the big
reason for that is he really understood
how to play the duality of the
characters really well and a lot of that
just came from the voice
but i think the advantage that robert
pattinson had
was that this is a year two batman so
he's still figuring out exactly what
he's doing like he's a little reckless
he's a little ignorant not in a bad way
but he is a little bit unaware
of how the world kind of operates in
gotham city especially but he's he's
figuring it out
so i love the fact that in this movie
while there is a he is bruce wayne he
kind of is mostly batman for the whole
movie because like the riddler tells him
you know that's your that's your real
face that what i'm looking at that's the
real thing so he hasn't really fully
formed that philanthrop philanthropic
version of bruce wayne yet and i'm
excited to see how he evolves and how he
maybe brings that in to
the future films
so but i love the fact that we got to
spend some some time with a batman who
like
he's really just
one character he's bruce wayne out of
the costume he's batman in the costume
but his personality is very much the
same in in both cases and i
really enjoyed that and you know he does
have a little bit of an internal
struggle with that and i think what
robert pattinson did so incredibly well
is he is able to bring that intensity
and when he has the mask on you know we
always talk about how batman can't
really do a lot of facial acting outside
of his eyes in his mouth and i think
pattinson was really able to figure that
out and even the way he just looks
around in a room when he's you know like
i would imagine that he would feel
batman would feel very uncomfortable
being in a room full of cops who really
don't trust them or don't know what he's
all about so his focus is really just
laser focusing on that's a clue that's a
clue that's a clue and pattinson is so
good at just being completely focused on
the mission itself and i think that's
something that we haven't really seen
before from a batman and that also
obviously go into you know him being an
primarily a detective in this movie
which i loved um so i think pattinson
really was able to hone in on what's the
most important part of being batman and
how do i translate that without really
saying almost nothing in a lot of scenes
and i think the mannerisms and the way
he moves it's almost like a shark in
some in some regard it was done really
really well so i feel like he really had
a good understanding of how to do
the most with the least amount of effort
and i think that is kind of a hard task
when you're playing somebody like batman
who you're almost immediately going to
be judged and compared to everyone else
that came before so i i think he did an
amazing job
i
cannot agree with you more on all of
what you're saying and that's the one
thing that really hit home for me was
whether he was bruce wayne whether he
was batman
you felt the pain you felt the anger you
felt the rage one thing i thought was so
cool that matt reeves did was in the
very opening shot you see
from you know the riddler's point of
view him
peeping on somebody through a window
and then you also see
batman doing that to selena kyle and so
it's kind of like saying at the
beginning of the film what
differentiates these two people
you know are they really that different
after all and then there's a whole
evolution that takes place to the very
end when that when you know spoiler
alert when pattinson's like beaten the
crap out of or batman's beating the crap
out of that you know copycat riddler
that's out there you know one of those
times and he and he's going he's going
and you feel the rage that when he was
he wanted to hit daniel that hard
through the glass and couldn't and he's
taking it out on this guy and then
he stops himself and that's the full
circle moment and then he saves the kid
and i got chills like
the kid the kid thing the kid payoff at
the end was so great okay so let's talk
about uh paul dano as the riddler what
are your thoughts
again another casting i was super
excited about prisoners is like a movie
i will shout about until i lose my voice
and if people have not seen prisoners by
denis villeneuve please go watch it paul
dano in that movie is incredible i mean
he's incredible in a lot of the movies
he's been in a little bit sunshine uh
swiss army man so i was excited because
uh primarily because of his performance
in prisoners i knew that he could bring
something
very unique very twisted very dark very
different and obviously matt reeves is
not gonna do the jim carrey version
because that is that is so jim carrey
that you cannot compete with that
it's that's just the truth and i love
that movie like i love batman forever i
don't care what anybody says uh
i like that forever i love those
schumacher movies i don't care i love
batman and robin you can you can say
whatever you want about that i love that
movie i love camp i love over the top i
love camp like come on like if you don't
have a sense of humor get the hell out
exactly
when paul dana was announced to be
playing edward nashton
the riddler i thought okay this is a
this is a really cool choice this this
is an actor who like
really really loves to like sink his
teeth into something that has a lot of
depth and has a lot of emotion and has a
lot of terror
what are they gonna do and then we found
out that it was gonna be kind of a take
on the zodiac killer and i thought oh my
god this is going to be
mind-blowing like fincher zodiac movie
is so good
and it's like that whole i mean it's
real life story so it's incredibly
tragic
but i think like being able to use that
as a concept to get into that character
i was like this is
genius so i already knew at that point
that matt reese was already going for a
darker more horror thriller tone and you
know i i didn't know exactly what the
look was going to be or what he was
going to sound like but then you see
that first teaser and you hear him
talking and you just hear the very few
lines that he says and i already knew
okay this is a guy who really understood
how to like how to really extract
something really menacing from a
character that sometimes in the comic
books is frightening but a lot of the
times he's not i don't want to say
comical but there's definitely a lighter
tone to him at a lot of certain points
so that was really exciting for me and i
think again paul dano another actor that
i love who did an incredible job
i think paul dano should be nominated
for this performance personally
he
he captured serial killer
psycho and i think to me those are the
most terrifying villains like
he's up there with uh like a hannibal
lecter type performance where
the scariest thing is somebody who's
unpredictable yes and almost like that
diner scene when he smiles
like the dinosaur by the way by the way
the way it was shot yeah that homage to
the iconic you know shot from you know
way back but like he just that smile but
then there was so much range in his
performance and then the jail scene when
he has that huge monologue like the
range of that performance and how
terrifying it was
and really closely mirrored a lot of i
think unfortunately knock on wood some
of the people that we've seen in media
who take out
you know like without going any further
like it was
eerily awful in that way and very
haunting
felt very visceral
and yeah go ahead what were you gonna
say yeah i mean and i think you know i
think the dark knight
kind of touched on a little bit of those
things where you had joker doing video
recordings of himself and and kind of
acting to camera
and
he also kind of has a little bit of like
a following that he kind of um
that he kind of collects by the end of
the movie and
the dark knight does it and it's kind of
ahead of its time a little bit a little
bit yeah but then this movie does it and
it's very much of its time and i was
kind of surprised that they did lean
into that
and and showing you know kind of what
it is a reflection of things that have
happened in real life
and sometimes you know we look at that
like oh that's a that's a fun fictional
take on a character i'm like yeah but it
is
inspired by like real life things of
course it's got a little bit of like a
veneer of this comic book movie-ness
yeah but
you know like that was one of the more
more surprising things was like wow they
weren't afraid to kind of lean in and
say like this is not as you know we're
basing this movie in reality it's
grounded as much as possible
and like this riddler character is kind
of a reflection of things that we have
seen
in media and in our lives you know today
and that is that i think is terrifying
especially because he is a character who
thinks and these are usually the best
villains are the ones who think that
they're always right and they're doing
the right thing
but it's just the way that they go about
it is like it's so extreme and it's so
terrifying
um what did you think about so let's
move on to zoe kravitz as selena kyle
aka the beginnings of catwoman
uh i just thought in this
okay i'm gonna be cheesy for a second
those two together on screen are like
the supermodel version of any other
iteration we've ever seen
nothing to take away from the gorgeous
humans that have played you know
catwoman before i mean some of those
beautiful women of all time
but i think the physicality of zoe
kravitz the way she moved
and just
you know i know matt reeves was asked
about why he cast her
and
he very simply said she really had the
physical attributes from
comics and like really had the look and
you hear people getting cast a lot for
their look and i'm always like
how they look they don't have to do
exactly but in this case it really
worked and her movements how tight her
movements were like when she came down
the fire escape at that moment and
that's when pattinson's like looking at
her and realizing how powerful she is
like what a badass she is um but what
were your thoughts about about zoe yeah
a lot of the similar stuff you know
again she's another actor who's been
really making incredible acting choices
and you know mad max fury road isn't the
first movie as far as i know isn't the
first movie that she did but it was like
the first movie that i kind of was
exposed to her and slowly just kind of
following what she'd been doing
when that casting was announced i was
like yeah she if you just look at the
sil her silhouette not even in costume
just as zoey kravitz and you know she
has the short hair it really does look a
lot like the some of the more recent
comic book renditions of catwoman so i
was excited to see what she could what
she could bring to the character into
the role and yeah i mean the way she
moves the way she just delivers dialogue
her quippiness the way she puts you know
bruce wayne in his place sometimes i
loved all that and i think she was a
really she played off of pattinson
incredibly well and i mean with every
actor that she has scenes with you know
there's an amazing scene with her and
john turturro that is just so
uncomfortable and you as the audience
are trying to figure out like what's the
relationship here and if you know the
comics then you probably very quickly
have an idea of like what the
relationship is yeah but i think she
delivers that so incredibly well and
she's incredibly you know the fight
scenes that she does she's just like a
great performer all around i think when
you are
doing whether it's batman catwoman
whatever
as an actor i would imagine you have to
be kind of willing and open to kind of
just throw yourself in there and be
willing to do
anything and this whole cast seems like
that's what they did and i think it's
really nicely reflected uh in the final
piece
what did you think about their chemistry
together because for me like i didn't
even need them to kiss like to me it was
more powerful
that
and it's very rare in film that you see
two counterparts that are so perfectly
matched that you look when he looks at
her
you know exactly why he's so captivated
by her captivated by her
he also is captivated like they're
they're equal they're on equal playing
field i think wonder woman got that
right the first wonder woman got that
right where she and steve were on equal
playing ground and they sort of went
through the journey together that's what
i like to see i don't like to see
you know a female that's sort of thrown
in and you're like okay it could have
been disposable or they try to
when they try to hard to make a woman a
badass as a female i'm like it's okay
you don't have to try so hard and they
didn't like she just had her own special
intensity
power
and to me the two of them i thought they
had a lot of chemistry
just physically they matched up in every
way they matched up
i don't really care about the romance
part of it right yet i feel like they
almost could have held back the kiss
and built that tension for the next
movie i didn't need it what did you
think yeah and i think you know the
advantage of using a character like
catwoman in the first movie is she does
constantly go back and forth you know
she's kind of in that gray area where
she can be a hero anti-hero villain
and like i think that's what's kind of
fascinating about the character and i
think using her the way that they did in
this movie where she's more good than
bad for sure and she's also put in
circumstances where she has to make some
choices and do some things that are
questionable but because of the
circumstances you are completely
invested in her and you completely
you're very empathetic to the choices
she has to make
and when it comes to their relationship
and you know
that one kiss that they do have yeah
like it's firing on all cylinders i mean
just look at the photo shoots that they
do together
i made a joke to my friend i was like
i'm just going to tell my kids that
these are their grandparents and
their chemistry is insanely insanely
strong just in photographs and i think
that's that's hugely reflected in the
movie and i think they do really work
well together and you know they have
they seem like they have a very
playful
friendship you know just even looking at
the uh the stuff from the interviews
that they've done together and i think
that's why i think that's why tom
holland and zendaya work so well as mj
and peter and i think that is again with
reflected in this relationship as well
so you know the ending is kind of less
ambiguous we don't really know what
happens to selena but i do hope that in
a sequel or maybe the third movie when
we get to see her again that we can kind
of continue evolving that because i do
think that the relationship between
selena kyle and bruce wayne is very
interesting and i think they learn so
much from each other about not just not
just as people but also
fighting on the right side of the law
when you can kind of bend that bar a
little bit and so i think it makes for
really good interesting storytelling do
you even do you care to even rank her
amongst the cat women i just think
you know like pfeiffer
pfeiffer delivered her campiness she was
so iconic for the one-liners and being
so the top where this one is so it's so
different but do you have a
ranking so to speak oh that's so tough
yeah i mean i would say right now
i probably would put zoey kravitz at the
top and then i would put michelle
pfeiffer and michelle pfeiffer was like
oh my god like so
so amazing in that role like i i really
do feel like she should have
been given at least the best supporting
actor nomination for that performance
um because she's so good or even just
like a best actor nomination for that
because she was so so good i think the
difference with her version in this
version is that catwoman is so much or
selena's so much more integrated into
the story
and she's so much more tied in with
bruce's story in the gotham story in
batman returns you know it's it's a
little bit separated but i think that's
also just
i think that's also just a product of
the evolution of how we make these
movies and all that stuff so it's not a
knock on her at all um and i love anne
hathaway too and i also love zoey
kravitz's cowboy in the lego batman
movie like she's great when she plays
that character in that movie as well um
and then of course you can't leave out
the 60s versions earth the kid julian
umar like that's classic stuff so but i
think right now zoe kravitz is at the
top of my list
outrageous i loved at the very end too
that he's looking at her through the
rear view mirror but then they never
show her the pov of her looking back
like yeah she's sad she asked him to
come with her but then she's like okay
you're not coming cool i'm gonna be fine
see ya
and she's not even driving slow like
she's hauling ass out of there
get out of this crazy town i'm out bye
but there's so much room for that
relationship to grow i just have to
point out and then we'll move on to the
next topic but i mean it kind of is part
of the next topic which is like people
praising the visuals and darker
atmospheres like is this one of the best
of the superhero genre like that scene
where she has the lenses on and she's
going through the club and he's talking
to her
what a brilliant idea yeah how scary it
was to see these men through her pov it
was such a reflection of
it was almost a statement on the world
too how men can be very threatening to
people to women and women don't even or
men sometimes don't realize how
threatening they can be
but like the way that that was shot also
that the way that they shot the riddler
stuff like through you know
the phone and that like was so eerie the
lighting and that so gritty
noir as we're all saying
dark
do you feel this is amongst the best in
terms of that in terms of in the
superhero genre oh absolutely like
there's no there's you you cannot ignore
that and i think i think it's it's also
telling that matt reeves and greg
frazier were willing to do a lot of that
stuff
um because i think sometimes with these
movies we focus on it being as clean as
possible looking really crispy really
clean and i think
i don't think that's an apply all to
every single superhero movie i think you
have to be willing to kind of get into
the dirt a little bit and this even goes
back like
they they went as far as to
take this film run it through 35
millimeter film create an inner positive
rescan it just so they could have like
the grain the the imperfections of film
on the movie and i'm like that's such a
specific thing to do
that most people would probably just do
it in a computer but you actually went
through the process of like physically
printing this movie and then rescanning
it like they were really i think the
the look and the feel and the aesthetic
the aesthetic and like it feeling
very um tangible was super important to
them and i think just using lens videos
and all that you know it creates these
really interesting looks on the film and
that's something that like you normally
do not see
in in any of these superhero movies so i
really appreciate them going to those
depths to really help translate like
what they were going for and i think it
really helps tonally to sell the movie
and make it feel almost voyeuristic in a
lot of the sense because we are it does
feel like at times we're put either
being put into the perspective of batman
or the riddler or we're meant to feel
like we are literally standing three
feet away from them and i it makes you
feel really uncomfortable at times but i
think that's what's so genius about the
way that they made the movie that's
exactly how i felt i felt like i was
there and the fact that it was visually
dark
and a few times i'm like and just like
when you're straining to see batman in
the shadows and you're screaming to see
things and like when they would do the
reveal of the batmobile which we'll get
into oh my god
when you're straining as an audience
member you feel like you're there like i
forgot that there was
an audience in my theater that i wasn't
right there i felt like i was in that
and i'm just going to say something else
they may edit this out
there was a lot of wetness in this movie
a lot of wetness
and we see a lot of rain in movies and
they're like oh it's very noir it's
raining but you could see the freaking
water soaked into his like costume like
his bat suit and he was just like the
and then the shots of her boots and her
stepping into that water at the end and
and also the fact that there was so much
rain and and he was so wet throughout
and then at the end he was a moist boy
in this movie he was a moist boy
i'll leave it there but then and the
fact that the water came rushing into
the arena sort of like how everything
kind of had a callback and was so well
thought out what did you think about
another person i actually think should
be nominated colin farrell oh my god
it's amazing that that that makeup that
prosthetic work that has to be an oscar
nom easily like if it doesn't there has
been something really mind-blowing that
comes out that has to that has to be
because that
i when i first saw the the very first
teaser at dc fandom and he's at the end
of the trailer and he's like this guy's
crazy when i was talking about the film
i thought he was just like some random
like carmine falcone thug
i had no clue until i looked up on imdb
that that was colin farrell as the
penguin i was completely sideswiped by
that
i think he he is he's having the most
fun in this movie and i think it's such
a benefit to the film because having
like one character at least one
character who is just chewing up the
scenery is fantastic and colin farrell
such a great actor and i'm so excited
about the hbo max series that he's going
to have
and i think it adds like just such a
like the scene with him batman and
gordon where they haven't tied up and
he's telling them like this riddler guy
must be real stupid he doesn't
understand the difference between alan
la and it's just just all those little
moments
is just so perfect and i i love the way
he just went for it and i think you
all these movies sometimes have an actor
that does that i think nicholson does
that devito does that carry
heath ledger obviously did that and now
you have this they have colin farrell
doing and i'm like this is this is great
i can't wait to see more of this
character
yeah i thought that
it's funny because
sometimes i think if you're buried under
prosthetics
you maybe have to overact or
overcompensate or the process will just
do all the work for you as an actor but
you could see beyond the prosthetics
this was not colin farrell as we've seen
him before in any role
and i think
what a job he must have had he changed
his voice too and jeffrey wright his
voice they were all top notch peter
sarsgaard they all knew like there was
not a weak link there was nothing where
you could have said andy circus was
perfection like
i just feel like everybody was firing on
all cylinders but him to me like that
was a performance where you just go oh
my god beyond all the makeup
it wasn't him like i've never seen him
be that way before and what a leap of
faith for them to hire him and then
decide later okay this is this is where
we're going to take it because i think
it was sort of colin was hired and
didn't realize that that's what they
were going to do
yeah absolutely and i think you know
again this kind of goes back to like
what are people's collective memory of
of certain actors and certain
performances you know you you ask
most people they might cite daredevil
from 2003 where he played bullseye it's
probably one of the first american
movies for pro in the first films he had
done
you know and he's done so much other
amazing things since then killing of a
sacred deer all this stuff
he has a new movie that's out right now
that i want to go see really really bad
so i i
i knew that he was the the right guy to
bring something different to it i just
wasn't expecting what we got but it was
so perfect um all right let's move on to
the batmobile the razero lupine cycle we
were talking about it before that scene
and then the car chase scene i'm just
going to let you rev and go
so
i saw the movie in imax for the first
time
you see a little bit of the car in the
trailer all of a sudden you're in that
sequence and you have colin farrell you
know doing his great thing and yelling
vengeance and shooting off his gun and
then you hear this loud
car engine rev up
the seat started shaking i was seeing
with a friend of mine i grabbed him by
the arm and i was like
you might have to bleep this out i went
holy sh
i was completely just like my jaw and
you've had incredible batmobiles
ever since the burton movies you know
like that batmobile is amazing all the
iterations have been so cool it wasn't
even necessarily the look of this car it
was the fact that it was completely
silhouetted with this burning exhaust
and with this jet engine sound and he's
just taunting penguin and revving and
revving and also he takes off and they
go on this incredible chase sequence i
was like this is
amazing i love this like just the sound
design alone i'm like give this scene an
oscar for how incredible the sound
design work is but yeah the chase is
so cool and i loved how they were
willing to use the cameras mount them
literally everywhere on every part of
the vehicle i love the 50 50 shots of
colin farrell in the foreground and the
batmobile in the background it makes it
feel like
you know christine like you're being
chased or jaws like you're being chased
by the monster in the back and i just
loved all that work and some of the
technical things that they did like they
put
filters over the lenses so the rain
would just sit and drip down the lens
you know we talked about the wetness of
the movie but like really using the
environment so incredibly well
and even some of the visual effects
shots where batman you know jumps the
ramp and then it's a practical shot
where he lands like it's just so
incredibly well crafted and matt reeves
talked about how they actually were able
to design that whole sequence in vr
because they had like a long freeway
and in vr he was basically able to like
take every single shot design it you
know take screenshots of that and then
they would go and film it and i'm like
this is such a technical feat and it's
not that long of a sequence in the movie
but every single shot is just so
purposeful and i i i like i hate it that
was so well done
yeah and i think he talked to us about
it he talked to rotten tomatoes in in
depth about the use of vr in the film
and and it's going to only
keep you know evolving and growing and
it's going to aid in filmmaking moving
forward and this is sort of like an
exciting i have one wish from that car
chasing it's funny because i'm not
really a muscle car girl like when i see
a dude drive by me in a mustang or a
muscle car i'm like whatever
it's not really my thing and so actually
when i first saw the car i was like i
don't know it's not really like the
tumbler the tumbler was kind of cooler
but then it was the whole action scene i
have one wish and that is
they revealed that upside down shot from
the riddler's point of view and then the
batman comes through the flames
in either the teaser or the trailer i
wish they had saved it for the film i
wish they hadn't shown it to us ahead of
time because that payoff and i just love
that the car came in
the reveal came in just at that moment
where you're like how are they going to
get out of this like they're all indeed
at this point yes they're not gonna and
and it was just so perfectly timed like
that the editing of this film um was
super tight but what you were saying
about the sound if you just want to talk
about that a little bit the sound the
score in this film another character i
think it was another character but this
is a you this is the perfect
film to show how when you have the sound
the editing everything is in harmony and
somebody has a director has such a
strong vision
for a film and he is paying attention to
detail and it all is working because
yeah the sound and every sound effect
you had in this film immersed you deeper
into it what did you think of the of the
score no i i totally agree and you know
i love the batman 89 film that tim
burton did and going into this movie i
had kind of hoped
that we could live in a perfect world
where a new batman movie would be a
little bit of a mix of burton's 89 film
and batman the animated series which i
think batman anime series is like one of
the greatest depictions of batman ever
and this movie surprisingly kind of did
that and the music is a part of that too
because i think when i when i think of
batman i think the hans zimmer score for
batman vs superman or his batman theme
in that movie and the dark knight
trilogy score is really really good but
there also is a part of me that
immediately can't help myself but to
start to think of the danny elfman
batman theme
and that is kind of carried over into
batman the animated series as well so i
think what michael jacquino did so
incredibly well and he actually created
the score before the movie was even shot
is that
he really brought back a lot of those
like
those sounds those deep bass sounds yeah
you know like the drums the beating of
the drums the the a lot of the
orchestral stuff
and it really it just sucks you into the
movie like the more times they play that
batman tune
every time it like hits the drum hits
i'm always like okay now he's gonna show
up now he's gonna like it you're just
constantly being pulled closer and
closer to the movie and i think that
like you were saying you know it is its
own character in the film and all the
sweets that he does for each character
is so incredibly well done
um but by the end of it i'm like man
this is a soundtrack that i want to
listen to
all the time and but then you're missing
the sound element of it which i love as
well
yeah it's really really incredibly well
done and i think these superhero movies
sometimes
not always but sometimes the themes can
feel a little
more generic or they don't click with
you as well and i've heard some
composers say that if you walk out of
the theater humming the theme then like
maybe it was too much of a distraction
in the movie but i kind of feel the
opposite i feel like if i
can constantly kind of think of the
music you know whether i'm like
you know talking about the movie or if
i'm just like working on something and
i'm just humming that theme i feel like
that is a
that is a really deep connection that
you obviously made with the music and
the score and all that stuff so i i
thought it was great
um yeah and i stayed through it so it's
always weird to me when i'm sitting
through
like obviously you know you're going to
sit through the end credits because
you're going to get something in one of
these
very little in this one
but we didn't get something but it's
always funny to me when people leave
like why are you getting up again
i come in the visual effects industry so
i always stay for the credits because
i'm always interested to see what
companies worked on it if i know anybody
that worked on it so it's always been
like you know of course well the marvel
movies have programmed certain people to
stay through the credits but even in
marvel movies people leave and i'm like
have you where have you been since 2008
you know that this is like not the time
to leave right
i know it's like a few more minutes but
sitting through those credits and
listening to that no no
no no
you know i definitely went home and it
was it was like as i was driving my car
i had a moment where i thought it was
bad
i might have driven a little fast on the
way home um okay so let's maybe delve
into some things that people criticized
about the film and that was
i heard and i heard a lot about the
third act
being you know
not as strong as the rest of the film
i'll just say real quick i totally
disagreed watching it i think it's a
really hard balance when you're doing a
quote-unquote superhero movie there has
to be
a crescendo in some way and some films
and even films that aren't blockbusters
and i'm gonna just say at parasite
happen for me
where the ending was so different than
the rest of the film
that i didn't love the ending because
they go they go so they go in such a
different direction from the tone of the
film that i'm like you lost it you lost
me like i loved all the noir or the
whatever this letter and but i don't
think he did that i think it was a
really good balancing act
um you could of course dissect it but
what did you think
i actually i actually thought it was
really enjoyable i think what it does is
it it helps batman bruce kind of cement
his role in in gotham city and in this
universe you know he kind of goes from
being
not necessarily i would say he he kind
of the way he starts in the movie is he
does feel a little bit disconnected from
gotham city a little bit and i think the
the mayor she even brings it up she says
like you know you you are this person
but you seem to be doing such minimal
work for the city
and of course you know just the idea of
him being batman and fighting the city
fighting back against the uh the
criminality of the city
that in and of itself is like already
you're doing so much for the city but i
think what the ending does is it helps
connect them to the people
and i think that's something that
sometimes in the batman movies we see a
little bit less of you know we don't
really see how what batman does affects
the people that are you know in gotham
city and i think the moment of him just
extending his hand
and leading all of those people out with
the flare
is like that is that just says that just
says so much about where that batman
ends up at the end of the movie like he
is now assuming this hopeful leadership
role of taking down crime so i think
without that ending it doesn't you can't
have that
um i love the dark knight
the ending of that movie
where you you know you put the two boats
against each other and you're relying on
the people of gotham to make the right
choice
not the most compelling strong ending
for me but like everything leading up to
that movie i i absolutely loved but i
don't really like knock the movie for
because of those final like 15 minutes
but with this i think it really really
worked and you know the way that he
narrates the end and he comes to terms
with the fact that like i can be the
hope for the city but i have to kind of
do it this way and i this is how i can
kind of lead i i loved all that i
thought it worked really really well for
me is there anything that really didn't
work for you not even necessarily the
third act but sure
um i was a little disappointed with how
little alfred we got and
this is less for me and more for people
who maybe
aren't as well versed in the comic books
or you know maybe don't have such an
attachment to that relationship i've
lived with that relationship for over 30
years
so
when alfred potentially is going to die
i have a lot of emotion for that
but when i look at it just on a film
level and it's you know the first film
of a new trilogy they really only have
three scenes together and i know that
through exposition they kind of explain
he's a former you know he was the he was
the bodyguard of the waynes and all this
sort of stuff i would have loved to have
a little bit more i would have loved to
have a little bit more time with those
characters so when that moment happens
and he potentially is going to die i
wanted to really feel the emotional
impact but not because i have this 30
plus years of baggage that i bring to
the movie being a comic book fan
um and then the moment in the hospital
where bruce tells him
you know i would have been really upset
if if i would have lost someone again
that i really care for
just the slight change of you know him
saying that being someone who's like a
father to me or somebody that i love you
know i think that would have had a
little bit more of an emotional impact
so i love the take it's very much from
the earth one comic books
um and i love that like that's that's
surprisingly what i wanted and i did get
it but i hope do hope that in the
sequels we get to focus a little bit
more on their their relationship and how
it differs from the other relationships
we've seen in the past
and um
yeah i would say like that is probably
one of my biggest sort of
critiques of the film everything else
kind of works for me and fires on all
cylinders i think maybe a little bit
more time with bruce wayne maybe a
little bit more time with the riddler in
person
not so much through a a phone or through
a lens like i think you know for the
purpose of the story it worked but other
than that the movie generally is like
really working for me almost all the way
through
same i i mean i it's almost like trying
to find something i didn't like about it
it's just kind of nitpicking for the
most part because there wasn't anything
glaringly obvious i actually i'm going
to disagree with you i thought there was
just enough circus
i think if this wasn't you know setting
up for future films um i would say
i would agree because there wasn't a
huge payoff at the end i understand i
almost
like i think it was just enough because
i think it was almost symbolic of the
fact that batman was kind of overlooking
him or forgetting about him and their
relationship was estranged and so forth
therefore if you're showing a million
scenes of them together well
are they really like you sort of feel
like he was an afterthought right or and
then you realize towards the end or at
you know in the hospital scene that he
was you know he was pushing those
feelings away he didn't want anybody to
get too close but i there was one scene
in the beginning
where um
just that the way that they played off
of each other and you felt
you felt that relationship how they had
that deep familiarity with each other
but they weren't completely connecting i
thought both actors
played together really well for a second
i thought they were going to kill him i
thought they were going to kill him
i was like oh alfred's toast is how
we're starting this movie are you
kidding me i know come on man you can't
do this early andy circus is not just a
national treasure he's a world treasurer
you cannot do that so you cannot do that
to my heart
but i'm absolutely excited to see you
know more of the more of that
relationship and how it evolves because
i i do agree i think like
too much alfred would have would have
kind of taken away from how much of a
wall bruce has and you know he doesn't
let anyone through that well not even
alfred who is his father figure i think
maybe for me to feel a little bit more
of the impact i didn't i didn't even
need a ton more maybe like one more
scene right one more moment and i know
we're going to talk a little bit about a
very maybe fun cameo depending on who
you ask leave us in lead the charge go
for it uh i have a lot of mixed feelings
about the joker scene in this movie i
love barry kyogen i love barry kyogen
i'm glad you said his name because i
don't know how to fully pronounce it
properly
he's he's great i i did meet him briefly
at an event a couple years back he was a
very lovely guy um i've loved all the
movies that i've seen him in i've loved
his performances and you know his my
first exposure to him was dunkirk but
you know killing of a sacred deer and
even internals he's great and he brings
a lot of different things to the role
i don't know if i
need a universe
that has a joker immediately like we've
had so many iterations of the joker in
the last six years
and heath ledger did such an incredible
job and i'm like can we maybe focus on
other villains couldn't that cameo maybe
have been like victor freeze or pamela
eisley or just someone else that we've
maybe never seen or haven't seen in a
long time i don't want this constant
reliance on batman joker batman joker
they're really great characters and like
they are the ultimate ganging gang of
each other but
uh give me someone else please
yeah i think
i didn't mind the jail scene i didn't
mind that it was joker
but i think i just have joaquin phoenix
so ingrained in my brain as
the
joker at this particular moment in time
you almost like needed more time to sell
that character to the audience and
you're not gonna get that and it wasn't
like very all due respect but it's not
like he's a huge star where people are
gonna in the audience like in you know
people who aren't like movie people like
we are who three movies a year aren't
gonna be like look who it is it's tom
cruise and you know yeah exactly
whatever you know whatever yeah yeah no
no i totally get you saying that but
like there's not going to be that
i thought i thought it was cool i i like
that oh okay here we go i like the
riddle by the way the use of the riddles
in the movie oh my god i loved it but
yeah but that's it he's a great actor um
and
you know there's obviously a reason they
cast him and
you know but but i see i see what you're
saying so um so let's talk about the
next installment of the batman what do
you want to see
mary's just talked about mr freeze and i
love that character i think he has such
a compelling story and i think you know
the the the relationship he has with his
wife in the movie is so interesting and
how it leads him down a crazy path
um matt reeves has also talked about you
know
i have i have a very like um
i have a very hard time sometimes my
filmmakers are like oh it's grounded
real i'm like your batman has a contact
lens that can record anything he can zip
up his cape and he has like a glider
suit i don't really think you need to
worry so much about how do i justify mr
freeze having a freezing gun like we're
pretty advanced technologically that you
can come up with something and we'll buy
it so i i would love to see mr freeze i
love schwarzenegger he's great but i
would love to see some new
fresh take where we do something that is
a little bit more grounded gives us a
very personal story for that character
and how that works against our batman um
there are other villains too you know
like clay face and villains that maybe
are a little bit more fantastical but i
i do really think that matt reeves is
someone who could figure out how to how
to do it i would like to stay away with
from characters that we have um
that we've already seen multiple
renditions of you know joker two-face
you know now obviously we have a new
rendition of riddler and catwoman but
you know hopefully more with penguin as
well and i hope that the atrial max
series takes care of a lot of that work
as well but yeah so i would like to keep
going down this
detective path to see bruce wayne or
batman kind of develop this
philanthropic version of bruce wayne and
what that means and how that affects the
city and what does the cleanup of the
city look like and you know is it going
to be year two into year three or a
shorter timeline a longer timeline like
that that's kind of that kind of stuff i
think is really fun yeah i want to be
surprised i'm like show me your vision
i want to be surprised it's like you
said asking audiences what they want
well then you might just get more of the
same right like
you know i i want to be surprised as i
pleasantly more than pleasantly was with
this film um
all that said
thank you so much this has been such a
blast talking to you i feel like
foreign i want you to give yourself a
plug and let everybody know where they
can find you yeah first of all thank you
so much for having me this was great you
are absolutely right this is a movie
that you can easily talk about for hours
and hours and hours from the technical
to the storytelling um but my youtube
channel is heroes reforged uh that's a
channel that i that i do every week with
my good friends hector navarro and
augustine rios we do breakdowns and
reactions to new shows and movies we do
have a review of batman so if you want
to see your thoughts that is on there as
well all my social media is just my name
adam hlavik if you have any more
questions about any technical elements
of the batman i will do my best to find
the answers and let you know
well thank you again this was so much
fun um can't wait to see you for the
batman too and
hopefully it'll be sooner than that but
i'm nikki novak thank you guys so much
for watching the rotten tomatoes after
show we hope you had as much fun as we
did and yeah let us know your thoughts
we'll see you next time
you